let's go next to our caller from the 785
area code who is calling today from 785
hi David this is David and I've had a
quick question you've had a few videos
where you've shown concern over Trump at
his rallies where they where he seems to
either be high or low
you've got other videos where you've
looked at perhaps sudafed abuse and uh
other contestants from some of the shows
social concern about adderall abuse and
things like that yes what I'm curious
about is how we can get the mainstream
media to report on this or or to you
know use their sources in the White
House to to uncover some of this because
other than outlets like yours it seems
that no one's really looking at this and
related to that you know Trump has a
history of of using prostitutes and
other sorts of things I just can't see
that all of a sudden stopping what C
became president and it doesn't seem
like at least I haven't heard anything
about people looking into that he's
still using prostitutes during his
presidency and I'll take my answer off
the air all right well listen I I don't
know that some people are looking into
the Trump health stuff I mean we've seen
we've we've seen Tom Hartman do an
interview recently about about that but
I I think the only way that it's really
going to break into the mainstream is if
for example we start to see Democratic
candidates talk about it that would push
it into corporate media and then sort of
the the political mainstream if we have
a mass campaign - for example on Twitter
just constantly have tens of thousands
of people hammering on all of the
primary news anchors on CNN Fox News
MSNBC the network's etc it's going to
take a lot of work to get it into the
mainstream unless something big happens
where there is something so obvious that
it can no longer be ignored like Trump
during a speech you know his shirt flies
open and and bottles of pills fly out
right I mean like I'm sort of something
cartoonish I think it will take a lot
for
corporate media to start talking about
it as many of you know I am super
careful about where we publish and
distribute david pakman show content
it's a really important decision that we
make where do we want our content to be
we don't want to spread ourselves too
thin but we want to make sure that we're
taking advantage of good platforms where
our content could do well and over the
last couple of months I've been testing
publishing our content to a platform
called library that's lbr why I've
mentioned it once or twice before and we
are absolutely loving it it's a
fantastic platform where our revenue as
publishers does not depend on some
algorithm deciding whether an ad should
run before a video or not in fact it's
actually an ad-free platform where our
revenue is determined by the number of
people that watch our videos and also by
the tips that are left for us in credits
that are in platform credits it's their
own sort of currency so to speak by
viewers like you
and right now for people who sign up on
this platform it's completely free using
the link down in the video description
for every verified signup we get a
little bit of a credit and you also get
a credit of tips that you can then leave
on content that you like such as the
david pakman show content that we are
publishing so use the link down in the
video description
no algorithmic determinations about
whether we get to make money or we don't
get to make money or any of that stuff
all of our video content is being
published there use that link sign up
you'll get a credit will get a credit
and it's a beautiful thing and I'll
update you guys in a couple of weeks
about how it's going there's also a
contest that they're running whoever can
refer the most new users gets a huge
reward which would be a big big boost to
us so check it out link down in the
video description sign up let me know
what you think